i i think you know it's asking people
like do they understand their weaknesses
like
i you know the typical interview
question is tell me about your biggest
weakness everyone has a canned answer
prepared for that right
right i'm a perfectionist right okay
thanks
um so i asked him for naming your top
five weaknesses
and by three or four they really have to
think about it and they start being
honest
okay or somebody that sits there and
can't tell me five weaknesses okay
you're 21 years old
you're a graduate and you're already the
finished article probably not the case i
mean like confidence naturally comes
with success
um you know when you get you know when
you see the process through when you do
the deal it's gonna come but
i always say to to my guys in the
onboarding process
build build build half the battle with a
graduate who's in their first job is
convincing them that they can do it
like and now i massively believe in that
like build them up
reinforce that that and and reinforce
that positivity and encourage them
to to know that they can do it because
like i said at the beginning
recruitment is an accumulation of small
gains over a period of time
and if you can get somebody excited
about pulling a lead
excited about generating a really good
candidate that's half the battle